[Music]
voting is very important
and we know uh how important this moment
is so
make sure y'all get those uh ballots
filled out man
and uh you know take care of that side
uh because it will make a difference
and we want to see change and this is
our opportunity to do so
nba superstar lebron james making a
last-minute plea
for voters to make their voices heard
during the racial unrest that gripped
the summer james and his fellow nba
players halted the playoffs to demand
action on systemic racism one of their
goals was to increase
access to voting locations during the
pandemic pro-sports team owners agreed
and
during this election season more than
two dozen arenas and stadiums
across the country have opened up to
voters caitlyn huey burns gives us a
look
at this new voting experience god come
on over you ready to vote
this is not your average polling place
i'm
for me for good cramped community
centers church basements and school
cafeterias
voting this year is getting a major
league upgrade
with the pandemics training resources to
conduct elections
professional sports teams stepped up to
the plate to fill an urgent need in
their communities
over 20 nba teams are offering up their
arenas as early voting sites or
polling locations including right here
in cleveland
and here in detroit at the pistons
performance center you can vote early by
dropping off your ballot at a secure
drop box
and here in atlanta state farm arena
became the largest early voting location
in the state of georgia
as you can see it's a massive space that
allows for social distancing it's close
to transportation
and they offer free parking that's
really a win-win for everyone
they've also loaned their people and so
really come alongside the county to
provide additional manpower resources
they're used to having 35 000 people
show up to concert things like that
so voters you know easy peasy for them
it was the easiest thing ever
i'm like so happy the attitude of the
people were just like if you were going
to a game
they acted like they were excited for
you to come in and vote it's been so
long since
you know we've been able to go to any
games or anything so it's kind of nice
being in there
you know reminding me of good times
everybody was almost like they were a
voting team
because they all had on their shirts for
voting it was cute teams are involved in
nearly every aspect of the voting
process
charlotte residents have been able to
vote during carolina panthers football
games
stadiums like detroit's ford field will
store ballots and election equipment for
safe keeping in case of a recount
but it's the players who have been the
driving force
this was always about more than
basketball and while the season is over
[Music]
[Applause]
the work is not pushing their team's
arenas to be more
than a venue lebron james has been at
the forefront recruiting over ten
thousand people to serve as poll workers
through his group more than a vote as a
community we
really want change and
it doesn't not only just end in november
but it starts there
it starts there what is going to be the
effect of having these sports teams
involved in this process it was much
more than just saying we want to get out
and vote this year we needed
trusted voices people who would break
through rhetoric and actually
you know communicate to voters about how
to vote and how to make sure their
voices are heard this year
and that's really where our prominent
athletes and sports leaders played a
critical role
so hearing this information from your
local sports team is kind of like
hearing it from a trusted source
exactly at a time when we need more
trusted voices to provide
accurate information about our elections
it was you know a great
example of leadership and really helped
address a lot of our concerns in the
election administration world in
michigan as to how we were going to in
detroit in particular
meet these extraordinary needs of
elections this year and on election day
in cleveland
some residents will have their chance to
cast a ballot at rocket mortgage field
house
what safety precautions are you taking
to make sure that they'll feel
comfortable voting
first of all we'll do normal health
protocol we'll do temperature checks
we'll have everything socially distant
in terms of the machines and the setup
here
as well everyone will have been a mask
environment plus
we have an incredible amount of square
footage that are able to work with
in terms of even an environment that is
much more expansive
than what might be a typical voting
location that evil
enables to us to have even a greater
expanse between
people and and polling locations the
idea that you're
going to be able to come and vote in
your hometown arena
do you think that will have an effect in
getting more people out to vote
we certainly hope so this is a
destination everyone knows about
so we think making it easy safe
environment dynamic environment a fun
setting who doesn't love coming to the
field house
for cbs this morning saturday katelyn
huey burns
new york great job caitlin she was all
over the country for that one
yeah he liked that too didn't you yeah
that's good it's a triple stand up
i voted actually at madison square
garden and didn't think about it until
watching the piece that it is this idea
of the
broader space everybody was there and
they did cheer when you walked out just
in that enthusiasm
we'll hear a little more about later in
the show good thing that athletes didn't
shut up and dribble yeah
wow you went there well that's what
they've been saying it's true
true they make a difference that's right